I want some of your failed names
failed names yeah like what was what
were some of the options you had when I
was like when I was in sixth grade that
was when I first started to rap and my
rap name was uh Cracker Jack
I had I made a tape in my uh my bedroom
at my mom and dad's house I had I had
made a Cracker Jack tape and the first
song on it was called psycho's path
because I wanted to be a gangster rapper
so bad
and it was the scenario remix beat
and I sold that tape in my high school
there's people that have it somewhere
people paid you currency people people
when I was 12 years old I used to I used
to ask my mom if we could move to
Compton because
I swear to God
you wouldn't be here today man yeah